in order to work out the question when
will if if he keeps repaying this amount
how much will he how long will it take
right we want to let
uh a n
that amount off here we want it to be
zero
right so that's going to leave us with
this
10 000 minus 2500
that's equal to zero you can see you can
disregard the denominator right because
it actually doesn't have an effect on
the solution up here so i'm just go
then here i can divide by 2500 make my
number numbers a little
meter here but four minus just just that
guy
kick him over the other side actually
maybe kick kick in there so we have the
n on the left
but change the negative and now of
course just like before
when you're trying to work out time
you're always gonna have to bring out
logs right
so i'm gonna rewrite this as
get your calculator change your base
and i think the decimal we got was like
9.99 one
something okay now what does this mean
okay uh it's not the answer to the
question and it's not enough just to say
n equals ten from there okay what this
means is that
if we could pay at partway through the
year um you know ninety percent through
the tenth year ninth year
tenth year ten for you uh ninety percent
through the tenth year
that's the point which i could say yes i
can i have enough to actually fully
repay it right
but on the question said we hear the
amounts of repayments at the end of each
year
right so therefore have a statement at
the end here right
um johnny fully repays
after attempting
by the way i don't know if you find that
confusing or paradoxical
that after the fifth year he wasn't even
halfway
it wasn't even close to halfway but if
you double it
um you do get past there now how does
that work
five years i don't get to halfway but
then another five years
and i'm i'm finished as it were it has
to do with the way
interest compounds right i'll let you
think about it that when you've got this
amount the reason why
you make so little progress at the
beginning of the load
is because there's so much of the loan
left so it's earning lots and lots of
interest and it's slowing you down
so even though at the end you seem like
you've got a very long way to go
because there's less of their actually
earned interest your payments account
for
more okay uh moral of the story when
you've got a loan pay it off as soon as
you can
right get rid of it because it's the
time the beginning that's really costing
you okay
uh and by the way if you haven't worked
it out already because he goes for 10
years
and he's paying 10 grand every year how
much does he actually pay by the end
um double exactly right 50 doesn't sound
so bad
but the effect of time that's that's
what happens to loans
it's the same with my mortgage by the
way by the end i'll probably have paid
about as much in interest
as i paid for the actual amount i
borrowed
okay now let's see um we said in the
superannuation questions right
there were four quantities we could muck
around with there was um
the amount that you borrow okay
the interest rate we call that r um
here it's the repayments right but
before it was the amount that you
constantly invest so
since then payments i guess we call them
p and then the last one was time
right so we've been we've been playing
with different quantities here
so what will be the next question
suppose he says you know
okay tenth year that's unreasonable
that's a rip-off i'm getting i'm paying
so much interest so he says look
i want to stick back in my original plan
of doing it in five years
okay so i know i can't do it like this
in five years because i need an
interest-less
loan okay so therefore let's say
if he does want to hit the five-year
target after all
he still wants to borrow his 50 grand
and going as you know his bucket list or
whatever tour okay
um and he's still got his interest rate
to deal with so what's the last thing we
can adjust
this repayment here okay so here's the
question i want to pose to you
if he wants to repay in five years how
is he going to have to adjust
his repayment what will his regular
repayment
have to be